people go to the movies to be
entertained to laugh to cry to be
shocked but sometimes movie goers get
way more than they expected and end up
running for the door here's a look at
some movies that audiences just couldn't
take anymore
a Clockwork Orange Stanley Kubrick's
adaptation of Anthony Burgess's chilling
novel was instantly considered brilliant
dangerous and also a little maddening
actor Malcolm McDowell said he saw
people walking out of screenings in
droves with many viewers outraged by the
ultra violent content although Kubrick
stood by the movie a rash of copycat
crimes in England convinced the studio
to pull it from theaters there meanwhile
it became a smash in the US after all
Americans do love to dance
[Music]
Swiss army man everyone knows flatulence
can clear a room
but when Sundance Film Festival
audiences got a whiff of Swiss army man
it nearly emptied the theater according
to Variety why well Daniel Radcliffe
plays a rotting corpse up Paul Danos
character rides like a jet ski propelled
only by radcliffe's
natural gas the movie wasn't a total
stinker though critics have given it
mostly favorable reviews we hear it
people don't like other people's farts
The Blair Witch Project
while the low-budget of The Blair Witch
Project brought the exceptional
financial return to artists and films it
did cost a lot of viewers their lunches
the shaky found footage style camerawork
had people hitting the deck and not
necessarily out of fear many audience
members walked out due to nausea and
panic attacks while others gave up due
to the movie's flow pace hey there's
nothing scarier than evil logs and not
the poopy kind The Exorcist Warner
Brothers marketed the excesses are
something beyond comprehension and for a
lots of theater goers in 1973 that was
exactly right
thanks to word-of-mouth the film became
a must-see event but once the frame
started rolling many people couldn't
handle what they were seeing such as a
horrifying image of a little girl
twisting a head completely around or
well pretty much anything else from the
movie plenty of people were too grossed
out or terrified to finish the film
but others left because they were
offended by the religious implications
hey some religions to Stowe like pea
soup Jack relisha Reservoir Dogs Quentin
Tarantino's directorial debut
established him as a true talent and the
film's torture scene still serves as a
yardstick by which the concept of
twisted is measured the now iconic scene
was too gory for some people though and
it prompted many early exits but
Tarantino took it as a compliment he
said it never bothered me when people
walked out it just meant the scene
worked a little too well
famous horror makeup artist Rick Baker
left a screener drawing the scene saying
he was in a business of fantasy based
scares and Tarantino was dealing with
real-life violence Pulp Fiction
Tarantino's second movie won him an
Oscar for Best Screenplay but the film
wasn't universally beloved when it
the nonlinear storytelling graphic
violence and rape scenes led to walk
outs with Tarantino famously being
heckled during his acceptance speech for
the prestigious Parma d'Or at the Cannes
Film Festival and those who walked out
were luckier than some others who had to
be carried out the scene in which John
Travolta thrust the hypodermic needle
into Huma Thurman's chest caused
multiple audience members to faint The
Lion King the circle of life may sound
beautiful and song but some kids and
their parents didn't think it was so
fantastic when King Mufasa was
gruesomely murdered on screen by way of
a wildebeest stampede many shocked
parents had to remove their horrified
children from the audience guess it
gives a whole new meaning to the term
scarred for life
am i right lads or am i right lads
because the bad guy is name is scar to
get it please anyone thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which movies were just too much for
you to take